this program shows drugs being made sold
and used it features graphic content
that may not be suitable for all
audiences viewer discretion is advised
hollywood
[Music]
california behind the stardust lies a
different reality
hollywood usually ends up swallowing
people and eating them alive
on the streets hollywood plays host to a
thriving drug trade
around here and saw basically drugs
drugs drugs drugs drugs drugs
homeless crackheads panhandle for change
on the strip
all right come on
want to close up here let's crack
cocaine
fame hungry wannabes use drugs to cope
i've gone through many many doctors and
psychiatrists and
there has been those who will literally
just
give me what i tell them to give
me drugs help keep you up
drugs help keep you thin
and dealers and doctors are never far
away
patients would start coming in and they
would be like you're doc hollywood
this film takes you inside the world of
users dealers
traffickers
the dirty doctors and the police who all
make up the 350 billion a year industry
that is
drugs inc
it's 5 p.m and 22 year old deathy is
getting ready to go out
oh god
uh that's not human
as a model and sometime actor
deathy feels the need to network that
means partying
most nights of the week
take a party several times a day
there's
always something
to be done
there's
always fun to be had
but the constant demand to make the
scene
comes at a price
drugs
partying is so hard
it would be really really really
impossible to deal with most people if
it wasn't for drugs
just makes it a little bit more bearable
[Music]
born and raised in neighboring burbank
deathy camps out rent free in her
parents pool house
her living room a carefully confused
jumble of bric-a-brac
deathy is one of around 200 000 people
who live
work or hang out in hollywood california
25 square miles of real estate just
north of downtown los angeles
the city is known for its movie studios
that dominate its flat landscape
and for grumman's chinese theater
the walk of fame and the sunset strip
but for those who call hollywood home
the glamour is often a little tarnished
six miles south of burbank outside the
hollywood bowl
john is planning a tinseltown party all
his own
when we decide to party
it's when i come here
and i make money
thank you bro no worries
all right all right
[Music]
all right
only in hollywood
john is a vietnam vet who panhandles for
drug money
and he's good at it oh hey thanks
brother
i know
john was made homeless by the 1994
northridge earthquake
he's lived on the streets of hollywood
ever since
you guys have fun having seen
generations of young hopefuls come and
go
john is no stranger to hollywood's false
promises
whatever your dream it'll come true in
hollywood not true
absolutely not true
90 percent 99 percent of the drinks they
come to hollywood
exactly
[Music]
contrary to its glamorous image
hollywood streets are neither paved with
gold
nor safe
crime is rife
work is hard to come by
finding an affordable place to live
is almost impossible
deathy has knocked on fame's door since
her mid-teens
so far no answer
partying is the most tedious part of her
quest for fame
it's like let's all play pretend it's
hard to find the ones that are genuine
in hollywood there's a wannabe party
every night of the week
and no shortage of drugs
to help see deathy through
there's things that are just common
staples like
weed you know i smoke weed like every
day
but if i go out to party
pretty much anything's acceptable
on a typical night out
duthie powders her nose several times
and she's not alone
it's probably easier to ask a guy for a
bump
than it is to get someone to buy you a
glass of wine
it's a huge socializing factor i mean
obviously
it lowers in ambitions it
motivates you to meet people
deathy parties on
a player in a scene that's full of
players
all jostling for a chance to get noticed
[Music]
at the hollywood bowl
john has done well
passersby have taken pity on the
homeless vet and his dog
thanks
i have one paul him too
okay
yeah that's my boy
capone i've had him for 11 years
30 40
45 50 55 60 120. looking at 140 bucks
tonight bruh
tonight he's earned enough money to buy
a rock of crack
he's happy
all right folks this is it
that's crack cocaine that's what i'm
getting ready to put in my pipe
inhale
and have fun too
[Music]
dawn
17 miles southeast of hollywood
while networkers and panhandlers sleep
off the night before
el nota is already up and cruising the
streets
you see that um green sand right there
onto your left behind the windshield
right there that pleases notorious for
distributing big amounts of marijuana
kilos of cocaine
stuff like that el nota not his real
name has worked in the drug trade since
he was 11.
[Music]
i'm a runner
on
the middle of the
picture where i directly get buyers
they need big quantities and i take them
to the people with the work
i grew up in this
i'm just like try to get away from me
but it's all you know sometimes you know
but it's just what you know it's what
you do it's like it's like second nature
it's like tiny shoes you know
this is commerce california
where el notta operates
a working-class area just southeast of
la
this is an area where a lot of drugs are
distributed
drugs like
cocaine methamphetamines
heroin
anything you need you think this is a
place to get it pretty much
separated from the rest of la by giant
storm drains
commerce is virtually a mexican enclave
people are poorer than average
younger than average
and likely to be out of work
it's a perfect recruiting ground for the
cartels
everybody's tied up in this so one way
or another
and now they're like they got a relative
you know
everybody i'll guarantee you one that
everybody has a relative
involved in the drug game right here
that's for sure
a lot of times these people don't say
nothing bad or they don't want to they
may not fess up to it but
they're involved with it because
or they take the money but they don't
ask where it's from
among the drug dealing community here
hollywood's glamour fails to impress
honestly hollywood gets all the garbage
tinseltown ranks at the bottom of a long
drug trade pecking order
what they end up getting is like
the res the leftover stuff coming in
from cocaine and the methamphetamine
that's already been super stepped on
all the pure stuff is coming through
here from east la
south central
all the hubs
and in like little by little it'll get
to that area somebody from echo park
will buy
whatever amount that guy will step on it
and then he'll sell it to whatever
people are in hollywood or or
it's a little it's like a little ladder
dealers make money out of hollywood only
through markup and volume of sale
if you're a drug dealer and you're
living by hollywood you should be making
good money because
it's like all the dudes right there are
consumers it's party central right there
nothing but good stuff should be flowing
right there but when there's nothing but
bad stuff and they're driving
10
25 miles just so they can score
themselves some real good stuff that
tells you a lot right there
el nota acts as a link between the
mexican cartels and street gangs who
control la's retail drug trade
that means having to be on call 24 7.
this
phone goes off sheets are calling you
and i was like hey i need this can you
get this for me
he's under no illusions about his place
in the ranks
we're all expandable on this thing it's
just
a couple of words that's one of them
goes someone else can always be there to
take their place right five minutes it's
that simple
so they won't miss you that long
off this little road right here is a lot
of stash
and there's some guys that got caught
with like 40 kilos of meth taking it up
to alaska from out here uh i don't want
to talk about that star because i don't
know who they are those guys are cartel
guys
a lot of movement out there like for
math and stuff everything
suddenly some dealers spot el nota and
our camera
they begin taking pictures
yeah
this is like
[Music]
east l.a is not a great place to be seen
with a film crew
if you're a drug dealer
el noto is nervous he's been spotted
a lot of people conduct business with
i want them to feel uncomfortable
around me
talking to outsiders without permission
can be dangerous
you have to have the approval of the
drug cartel the drug
addressing get you killed
the city of commerce is a major drug hub
for the mexican cartels
cocaine heroin and meth come up from the
border to this part of la
here it is kept in clavos
or stash houses
basically stash i was just um a house
with like five six seven eight guys and
stayed every day taking care of the work
in the room they don't come out they
just stay in that room specifically take
care of the work
stash house crews break up pure coke or
meth into smaller portions mixed with
additives to make it go further
let's say for example you got a z
an ounce
from now she could easily i mean you're
gonna pay well you could pay 750 you
could easily put out 1800 out of it
if you break it out
but if you double up if you put cut in
there you can make you can easily make
like 2 500
from that 750 investment
el noda's day goes on
tomorrow will be the same but one day
he hopes to get out
wherever i go i don't want to
having to do this again wherever i go
there's nothing for the rest of my life
it's not what i wanted to be doing to
begin with but but it can't be this
el nota and dealers like him walk a
tightrope
[Music]
police are always on the prowl hoping to
catch the unwary
we just keep doing what we're doing to
fight the war and catch the bad guys and
put them in jail
tonight la sheriff's deputies are
raiding a house somewhere east of los
angeles
we're doing an investigation
into a um
individual who's trafficking large
amounts of
methamphetamine
so right now they're getting into
position and they're going to get ready
to
make entry hopefully we'll find some
product and
if there is
we'll take some people to jail
the deputies decide to keep it low-key
but are alert for trouble nevertheless
when you're dealing with these
individuals you can't predict what
they're going to do and how they're
going to react
with surprise on their side they swiftly
gain access to a respectable looking
apartment
on the sofa in plain view that's
approximately one pound of
methamphetamine
part of a cartel stash
the occupant offers no resistance
is your name emilio what oh
for that stuff right there on your couch
what is this
what are you thinking we got drugs in
your apartment now
is your name emilio yes or no
[Music]
the deputies make a rapid and thorough
search
as the interrogation gets underway
when you start uh selling math
you started selling when you were 12.
what's the most amount of dope you've
ever sold 20 pounds 30 pounds
around there
they soon strike gold
[Music]
it's evidence of drug cells taking place
on the premises
we found some samples here so basically
just kind of like giving out free
product to see if they like it if they
like it they come back and buy more
by mixing retail and inventory the
trafficker is played into the hands of
the police
he'll face more charges and maybe longer
time in jail
all in all a good night's work for the
deputies
it went down
well
the amount of
product that we were anticipating
to
get wasn't there but we got a nice nice
amount that was a good amount
a small victory
and tomorrow is another day
[Music]
the mexican cartels exert a powerful
grip on the drug scene in hollywood and
la as a whole
but they have competition
[Music]
in burbank deathy is chillaxing by her
parents pool after a hard night
partying she got into drugs as a
teenager when her doctor diagnosed her
as having bipolar disorder
she quickly took advantage of her
condition
[Music]
it's like the little prescription fairy
tale
when i found out i was mentally ill i
used it as a great excuse that was in
paper
and documented
that i am a crazy
i took liberties with it
in her experience
some hollywood doctors seem all too
ready to reach for the prescription pad
i've gone through many many doctors and
psychiatrists and
there has been those who will literally
just
give me what i tell them to give me
doctors themselves
aren't always immune to fame seductive
power
uh wire's good we're ready to go
in 2009
dr nathan kimberly a west hollywood
psychiatrist
came onto the radar of the dea
okay so then i'm going to do the um
30 twice today is that right okay
perfect
local police had busted one of
kimberly's patients
trying to sell a powerful prescription
drug online
the patient figured kimberly as his
connection
the dea sent an undercover agent wired
for video to find out more
several undercover buys here and
meetings with dr kimberly we would sit
over at the restaurant across the street
and monitor it we would sit up there at
the corner and monitor
agent mark nomity has been with the dea
for 25 years
in the last five he's seen prescription
pill abuse become an epidemic
one that he means to stamp out
in the united states prescription drug
overdoses accidental deaths related to
prescription drugs just surpassed
traffic accidents as the leading cause
of death
but at the start of the kimberley case
the dea had no idea of what it had
stumbled upon
by private practice it was always in
hollywood
dr nathan kimberly began his career like
any psychiatrist
but just like any wannabe
kimberly gets bitten by the hollywood
bug
famous actors like when they would say
oh this person has just done another 20
million dollar film or whatever like
there's just so much energy when someone
like that comes in that you it's almost
like you don't know what to do
this is like major you know somebody
huge right
i can't tell you
she's on the cover of cosmopolitan
magazines right now
kimberly soon becomes hooked on the
hollywood buzz around his celebrity
patients
he begins signing prescriptions without
asking questions
and the stars show their appreciation in
return
and they're like
oh i lost my scripts for the tenth time
in three months and and i mean could
just fill it doctor and then they're
suddenly like oh by the way um
i have an extra pass
to like this vip party
for the academy awards and you can have
a vip pass
and literally i'd be like standing next
to michael douglas steven spielberg
sally fields celebrities fighting at a
party
it was really seductive
kimberly's most popular drug is
amphetamine salt an antidepressant
widely known by the brand name adderall
abusing it is highly dangerous
there's no difference between
distributing
adderall without any type of legitimate
medical reason and distributing
methamphetamine on the street corner
that we're doing today
i'm sorry is it foreign
doctors prescribe amphetamine salts to
treat adhd
a condition that has no biological test
and that makes it easy to fake a
diagnosis
i'm telling you this is going to be
pegged in
pretty awesome adhd is power
taken in large doses adderall makes
users high
and suppresses appetite
and everyone just started getting
seduced it's like well if if they're
doing so good on adderall and you would
actually see these people's lives get
transformed
kimberly's business rapidly takes off
he soon becomes hollywood's go-to guy
for amphetamine salts
in the process he acquires a kind of
fame of his own
i made adderall fashionable
right
patients would start coming in and they
would be like
you're doc hollywood you know it's funny
because it's kind of like glamorous
right
before long
dealing is all he does
he was
charging 150 a patient
and then he was seeing
you know easily 20 or 30 patients a day
so you know he's making
six seven eight thousand dollars a day
in cash
doc hollywood has become the biggest
adderall dealer in the state
i prescribed three and a half times more
adderall
than any other doctor in california
there was like 1.3
million
adderall tablets
with business booming doc hollywood
starts to branch out
and that's when the trouble really
starts
it's gonna make so much money
it's such a huge hit it's like
a shining star
dr nathan kimberly is beginning to crack
under the pressure of life as a drug
dealer
i was high a lot i was experimenting
with different drugs i thought it was
really clever
you know like i thought oh i could you
know if i if i do some
crystal meth this weekend on a friday i
could knock myself out on a saturday
night and knock myself out again on a
sunday night with xanax or something
like that
and then show up as if nothing had
happened
right but i i didn't realize but i was
getting more and more grandiose
it's the oldest mistake in the book
don't get high on your own supply
once addiction gets hold the only way
for kimberly is down
i masterminded that with this it's kind
of like evil genius yet he continues to
grow his business i have the power of
all the doctors
he begins to expand his repertoire
he offers customers a tranquilizer to
help them relax
did you want genetics too yes
fantastic
i don't know how people would function
that have anxiety in this town
cautious of getting busted
kimberly is careful to check his
patients credentials
do you know any dea agents control
people california medical board yeah
anything like that
he's not careful enough
now the star of his own undercover movie
doc hollywood is arrested
in court he loses his license
after attending a one-year residential
rehab program he is lucky to get just
three years probation
chances are others will take doc
hollywood's place in serving the drug
needs of celebrity clients
anytime you have celebrities visibly
knowingly using prescription drugs
there's a certain amount of the
population that's going to want to
emulate that
like the rest of the us the abuse of
prescription pills is fast becoming the
biggest illegal drug problem in la
it's a huge problem i've worked gangs in
la for over 10 years and i've worked
heroin cocaine crack
you name it and
this right now is growing faster than
any of those
it's hitting all communities it's not
just
uh in one area it's in the wealthy
all the way down to the poorest because
it's pharmaceuticals people think that
it's safer
they tend to feel that i can do this
because it's from a doctor
7 30 a.m
agent jones and his team are on their
way to raid a house in suburban la
they got a tip that dealers are using it
to sell stolen pills
they have no idea who's inside
they approach armed and ready for any
situation
the agents bust in the door hoping to
find evidence that the house is an
illegal pill
in the house they find only two
teenagers
the key suspect their mom
is not at home
even so the cops take no chances
a 13 year old can shoot just like a
grown man
so you have to
uh secure them
you have to put them in handcuffs until
you know everything is safe and then
once everything is safe then we'll
take the cuffs off of them and explain
to them what's going on
the kids offer no resistance
the entry was successful
we just cleared it for officer safety
right now and then after that we'll
start our search
but the house search
comes up blank
so the team saddles up and heads to the
mother's workplace
an osteopath clinic
[Music]
once they gain entry agents find a stash
of pills in her office
they make a discreet arrest
the sad thing about these prescription
drugs is that the young people that are
dying from them it's crazy
you have to interview the families
because
their
20 year old kid overdosed because he's
popping these pills like m m's or
something you know
bus like these are taking pills off the
streets
but with a frightening consequence
once they cannot find a dirty doctor or
they can't get the pills
then they gotta go to the streets
pain pills contain ingredients derived
from opium and when you can't get them
street heroin makes a good substitute
i was just talking to the director of
the rehab they're getting heroin addicts
in there like you would not believe
in duffy's hollywood crew all her
friends are popping pills
some have ended up addicted to heroin
we're picking up my friend
she's actually staying in a sober living
facility at the moment
[Music]
among the hollywood party set
it's hip to get hooked
it's kind of bourgeois
it's kind of a luxury to have a heroin
addiction
it's become an epidemic it's really it's
like it's made a big comeback for young
people in rehab like all of us young
people were all there for heroin like i
heard about a bunch of kids
you know from hollywood and stuff that
i'm acquainted with doing it and like
doing it together and yeah those certain
movie stars daughter
i found that she was smoking it
uh i mean like
i had to stop because i couldn't afford
it
using needles is for hardcore junkies
wannabes prefer their heroine smoked
it's probably more casual and bourgeois
to be smoking it rather than like
slamming it um i've never i mean i've
never slammed it so
you know i i think it like i was
probably
a casual user yeah
heroin cocaine and prescription pills
come in and out of fashion in la like
hairstyles and handbags
but there's one staple
hollywood's confidence and a toke of
weed
i got here don i got
six grams
of a five
got a diamond good stuff
[Applause]
[Music]
stealing street drugs can get you killed
but in hollywood there's one high that
you can buy in the store
marijuana
medical dispensaries have been selling
weeds since the state of california
permitted its use for medical purposes
in 1996
it decriminalized sale and possession of
small amounts in 2011.
today it's a market worth an estimated 2
billion dollars to get legal marijuana
all you need is a medical card
the law lists a wide range of qualifying
illnesses homeless vietnam veteran john
got his card for chronic back pain
a doctor has to recommend a patient for
marijuana treatment before the county
will issue the card
the maximum you can get is 8 ounces
but doctors can authorize more
having just collected his welfare check
john is headed for the dispensary
hey excuse me this is payday okay
yeah we're gonna go give you some leave
we're gonna go get john's weed let's go
brad come on my little buddy
guys what have we got i need one round
of ten thirty five
up to a million californians may have a
medical marijuana card
no one really knows because card holders
don't have to register
critics claim the system is too lacks
somewhere else before we stood this up
okay
all right john's friend ken doesn't have
a card
no problem
it's easy for john to buy more than he
needs and to split the surplus
no questions asked
[Music]
we just went and bought
thirty dollars worth of waves at five
dollars a gram okay
now what do they got here
some nice big buds
20 of that
was my money
and 10 was kim
so i'm getting ready to break ken off
his ten dollars would we
hold on the system has enabled john to
cross the line from weed user to dealer
that's the way i'm done right
and then i got
this
which is the top of the line
and that's ten dollars a gram
one two two so three soaks okay that's
how we judge it
however many hits on the pipe it takes
to get snow knocking out
help
john sees his dealing as helping friends
he's not doing it for money
if i do this with our friends
that's one thing
okay
doing it to make a profit would be a
totally different idea
it's something that i don't do
haven't done an ever wilder
but because users like john can obtain
marijuana for others
come here you
established illegal dealers are facing a
problem
this right here
this is the scale this is how you weigh
out marijuana
yogi came to hollywood from upstate new
york in the mid 2000s to make it in the
movies
but like many others he found that big
break elusive
um there's i think only like
three four percent of all actors that
are actually making enough money to
survive off of because there's so many
actors so he turned to another way to
earn a living
selling marijuana
i did that back home and then you know
when things got a little bit rough here
i was like well
you know i'm pretty good at this you
know why don't i try my hand at it over
here
it was great for a little while it was
amazing
at first it was easy to find customers
i had everyone from
um
your average joe
to lawyers doctors to uh to everyone
i've had
average people i've had entertainers
singers
construction workers you name it
but now the explosion in marijuana
dispensaries
is causing yogi problems
there are so many dispensaries that have
come up it's difficult to
to compete with that there'd be times
where i would only have one or two
different kinds people are like okay and
just for some reason if that didn't
float your boat well you're stuck that's
all you got but when you go to a
dispensary you're shopping it's just
like going to one of these big
brand-name stores you get to look around
pick smell you know like when you go
shopping you try on a shirt you look at
it they also
a lot of people
can't smoke
don't like the smoke whatever it is just
they don't like the smoking aspect of it
that's where edibles come in this is a
sucker this is like a fruit shoot you
can buy them for anywhere from five to
twenty dollars depending on how strong
they are
yogi can't compete with variety price
and legality
his clients are deserting him
advocates of medical marijuana would
claim this as a victory for law and
order
yogi sees it differently
the big corporation is is taking me out
pretty much
at the end of the day people love going
in
seeing a variety seeing choices seeing
options and for them it's more
convenient
it's just it's it's the new trend i
guess
yogi turned to drug dealing when his own
hollywood dreams fell apart
others take more extreme measures to
cope with delusion
i cherish my
my misery
it's the best teacher
in the shadow of the world's most iconic
symbol of glamour dwells a secret drug
community
ramsay's been living in a tent in the
hollywood hills for six years
he's a frequent meth user
i don't like to
be all dead and comatose
i don't like to be out of control
i can focus a lot better on meth
and
it's also easy and quick
like many young people ramsay came to
hollywood from a small town out east
in pursuit of a personal dream
originally i came back out here for
fashion design school at brooks
uh which was basically just i always
wanted to get out of ohio and see
something different and i was 18 and i
just wanted to see california then once
i got here fell in love with it
the dream evaporated
but ramsay stayed
despite being homeless
ramsay prefers the life in tinseltown to
going back home
there's nothing in ohio there's nothing
even i want to do
no scene for music no art there's you
know i can't go sneak in like i know the
trail to sneak into the hollywood bowl
and i can sneak into the house of blues
and asking into universal studios it was
like
i can't do that i sit around watch tv
[Music]
crystal meth is fast becoming one of
la's most popular drugs
known as poor man's cocaine
it's one of the most addictive
substances on the planet
it does more damage to the body than
heroin or crack it's cheap and easy to
make
and it's everywhere it's easier to get
speed than probably anything because
well every day i get you know
you know anybody looking for any or
wanting to get me higher so yeah mess
a daily basis you come across math
the hollywood hills offer ramsey a
refuge and a safe place to get high
i won't come down off the mountain when
i'm high because
i'm not trying to get arrested
i'd rather stay up here without any food
no water with no cigarettes for days if
i have to i
i don't want to go down there and be you
know should make it worse and be out
there jerking and acting funny and
everybody's going to be looking at me
and everybody's going to know i'm high
ramsay's refuge is about to be disturbed
la county sheriffs arrive
the deputies are on a mission to move
the drug users on
it's fire season it's very dangerous
some of them will go down and use the
the neighbor's pools
to bathe in hey johnny did you guys see
this one
uh some get kind of aggressive with
their uh panhandling things like that
there's the end of the week the
robberies and stuff go up so what we try
to do is
we get them out of there
the best we can
the cops soon find evidence of drug use
there are needles
in the in the trash and debris
and that's not not uncommon
to find
you know drug paraphernalia and stuff up
here it's just not
the deputies are not here to lock people
up
they work closely with welfare groups
they'll give them food and
clothing
shelter they'll offer them shelter
the offers are usually rejected
they'll take the shower the clothes and
the food and then
they they choose to go back out on the
street
um if you're homeless or if you wanted
to be living on the street this is the
place to be it's not super cold and it's
not you know exceedingly hot
ramsay refuses to leave
as the sheriff's approach
he decides to make a stand
ramsay's resistance is short-lived
la sheriff's deputies quickly handcuff
him and escort him away
their sweep of the hollywood hills
continues
[Applause]
the cleanup costs a quarter of a million
dollars
but the deputies find nothing to charge
ramsay with
a few hours later
he goes back to set up camp
we are back up on the hill where i just
woke up this morning with a gun in my
face maybe it's not going to be as easy
as i thought but
it's either this or the sidewalk and
i've had too many friends wake up with
black eyes and busted lips and
so yeah but i'll just find a better spot
to hide my stuff so the cops can't stick
a gun on my face so easily
despite the risk of ending up like
ramsay
thousands of young kids dazzled by the
bright lights of hollywood come to la
dreaming of stardom
people get wrapped up
in the glitter and all that crap but
they don't realize it's not real glitter
it's plastic and it's got elmer's glue
holding it together
i don't know a lot of people that said
i'm going to come out to hollywood and
get high and be a junkie on the streets
but hollywood usually ends up swallowing
people and eating them alive
it's 5 p.m
22 year old deathy is getting ready to
go out
[Music]
i'm like
already confused
this is the sum of life for a wannabe
every day is the same
nothing changes the boredom is crushing
the prospects are not great
on the streets everyone is getting ready
to play their part in the never-ending
hollywood show
[Music]
john is back panhandling for drug cash
oh hey thank you
el nota is counting his coke stash
[Music]
ramsey is back on the hill hoping to
score some ice
doesn't matter to me as long as i'm
happy which i am so as happy as it can
be
deathy is philosophical
i don't believe in the future
i have learned
that
if i worry about the future that only
brings anxiety
and if i worry about the past
i will only be depressed
so always live in the present moment
because no other reality exists right
now
that's
true forever
for wannabes celebrities and street
addicts
the pressures of hollywood can always be
relieved by a powder or a pill
[Music]
you